breaking news in the last few minutes
the international monetary fund has
issued a dramatic upgrade of the UK's
economic Outlook saying that Britain is
no longer expected to suffer a recession
this year but the fund warned that there
was more pain to come in the cost of
living crisis our economics and data
editor Ed Conway spoke to Ian King a
short time ago it's a big change from
their previous forecast but to be honest
with you and you know you I remember we
had exactly this conversation about the
reliability of of any forecast right now
to be honest with you but in particular
IMF forecasts the last time they made a
forecast about the UK which was to say
that Britain was going to face the
weakest economic growth in the G7 this
year that was widely reported at the
time it was what the IMF was saying and
it was quite a big four you know it was
a big call to say the UK was going to
have a recession and then most other
countries around the Europe and indeed
the rest of the industrialized World
we're going to do a lot better but now
it's pretty much a reversal of that